good morning believe nation today's
message is enjoy the journey over to you
Bishop TD jakes
enjoy the journey not the destination a
lot of us delay our happiness when I get
to this level when I get my degree when
I get the kids when I get married I'm
gonna be happy enjoy the journey
enjoying the whole step the whole
process every day that you get up to
strive for whatever it is you're after
you know I'm a goal-oriented guy yeah
but you don't celebrate when you get to
the finish line celebrate all along the
way some way all along the way yeah man
my goal is to help a billion
entrepreneurs and a lot of people will
question that and say well how do you
know when you've helped a billion
entrepreneurs or are there even a
billion people who want to be
entrepreneurs in the world and is that
goal realistic or achievable and they're
they get so caught up on the specifics
of the goal that they miss the most
important part is that why I set that
goal is because I want to enjoy and
create a process that will help me get
to the billion because I don't care
about hitting a billion entrepreneurs I
care about the process of hitting a
billion entrepreneurs I'm making these
youtube videos because I want to be able
to reach a lot of people and have a big
impact on their lives because I enjoy it
because I see people consuming it and
leaving comments and seeing how much has
changed their lives and impacted them in
business and people watching it every
single day to get motivation ideas and
strategies that grow that's what I'm
addicted to that's what I love I love
that process where too many people do
the opposite they have this goal you
know I want to hit this amount of money
or I want to hit this kind of reach and
then I'll do whatever it takes to get
there and you end up doing the stuff
that you hate that you're not good at
that doesn't make you come alive and you
never end up hitting your goal the point
of a billion entrepreneurs for me is to
make me do big things make me do things
that have the ability to reach millions
of people at a time otherwise I'm not
interested in it and I enjoy that
process I think too many people stick
around too
in things that they hate with people who
they don't enjoy because they're too
afraid to jump to something else I had a
girl write to me today saying she wished
she could quit where she was right now
and she's unwilling to do it right now
where if you hate going to work if you
hate waking up every day and having to
go hang out with these people or do
these certain kinds of jobs then in my
view you shouldn't be doing it anymore
because people hang on for too long and
say well just a little bit longer just a
little bit longer just a little bit
longer just meanwhile you've stunted
your growth you're playing such a tiny
game because you're doing things that
you hate you cannot do something great
you cannot be amazing you cannot be the
best version of yourself when you are
day in and day out doing things that you
hate and you're around people that you
don't like it's just not possible and so
the sooner you quit that environment the
sooner you quit those you know that team
that company that opportunity that
you're with the sooner you leave that
and move on to something that you are
excited about you're gonna see your life
explode
you're gonna see massive transformation
you're gonna grow to places that you
didn't think we're possible because
you're doing the thing that makes you
come a lot and so for me I just try to
get there faster because I know it's
scary right it's scary to jump off
something that you may hate but is is
stable and you know it's predictable and
at least you know the crap you're gonna
get into today and it's scary to jump
off to something that is unknown but for
me as soon as I realize that I'm not
coming alive anymore I'm not enjoying
the process anymore I jump if I don't
like making youtube videos anymore
that's it
I'm gonna stop I will stop I will stop
today because I don't like making
YouTube videos anymore that they may
come I hope it doesn't cuz I get so much
enjoyment from it but if it does I will
and I think a lot of people have you
know you've built up so much success
with something or at least so much
attraction or so much history even it
was not successful just you put so much
time and energy into something that it
becomes an anchor for you that you
cannot cut it and move on to something
else and you continue to play down here
with minimal increment
growth instead of shooting up here to
something that you can be amazing at it
makes you come alive so you have to
enjoy the process if you are not
enjoying the process anymore and
whatever you're doing you have to leave
immediately and go chase something go
find the thing that makes you come alive
where you can enjoy the process
so the question they today is I want to
know what you enjoy most about your
business and what you're doing what
makes you come alive about your company
leave it in the comments below and I'll
join the discussion thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of entrez